[Music]
the last several videos have been about
the idea of a derivative and before
moving on to integrals I want to take
some time to talk about limits to be
honest the idea of a limit is not really
anything new if you know what the word
approach means you pretty much already
know what a limit is you could say that
it's a matter of assigning fancy
notation to the intuitive idea of one
value that just gets closer to another
but there actually are a few reasons to
devote a full video to this topic for
one thing it's worth showing how the way
that I've been describing derivatives so
far lines up with the formal definition
of a derivative as it's typically
presented in most courses and textbooks
I want to give you a little confidence
that thinking in terms of DX and DF as
concrete nonzero nudges is not just some
trick for building intuition it's
actually backed up by the formal
definition of a derivative in all of its
rigor I also want to shed light on what
exactly mathematicians mean when they
say approach in terms of something
called the epsilon-delta definition of
limits then we'll finish off with a
clever trick for computing limits
called l'hopital's rule so first things
first let's take a look at the formal
definition of the derivative as a
reminder when you have some function f
of X to think about its derivative at a
particular input may be x equals 2 you
start by imagining nudging that in put
some little DX away and looking at the
resulting change to the output DF the
ratio DF divided by DX which can be
nicely thought of as the rise over run
slope between the starting point on the
graph and the nudged point is almost
what the derivative is the actual
derivative is whatever this ratio
approaches as DX approaches zero and
just to spell out a little of what's
meant there that nudge to the output DF
is the difference between F at the
starting input plus DX and F at the
starting input the change to the output
caused by DX to express that you want to
find what this ratio approaches as DX
approaches zero you write L I M for
limit with DX arrow zero below it now
you'll almost never see terms with a
lowercase D like DX inside a limit
expression like this instead the
standard is to use a different very
something like Delta X or commonly H for
whatever reason the way I like to think
of it is that terms with this lowercase
D in the typical derivative expression
have built into them this idea of a
limit the idea that DX is supposed to
eventually go to zero so in a sense this
left hand side here DF over DX the ratio
we've been thinking about for the past
few videos is just shorthand for what
the right hand side here spells out in
more detail writing out exactly what we
mean by DF and writing out this limit
process explicitly and this right hand
side here is the formal definition of a
derivative as you would commonly see it
in any calculus textbook and if you'll
pardon me for a small rant here I want
to emphasize that nothing about this
right hand side references the
paradoxical idea of an infinitely small
change the point of limits is to avoid
that this value H is the exact same
thing as the DX I've been referencing
throughout the series
it's a nudge to the input of F with some
nonzero finitely small size like 0.001
it's just that we're analyzing what
happens for arbitrarily small choices of
H in fact the only reason that people
introduced a new variable name into this
formal definition rather than just you
know using DX is to be super extra clear
that these changes to the input are just
ordinary numbers that have nothing to do
with infinitesimals because the thing is
there are others who like to interpret
this DX as an infinitely small change
whatever that would mean or to just say
the DX and D F are nothing more than
symbols that we shouldn't take too
seriously but by now in the series you
know I'm not really a fan of either of
those views I think you can and should
interpret DX as a concrete finitely
small nudge just so long as you remember
to ask what happens when that thing
approaches zero for one thing and I hope
the past few videos have helped convince
you of this that helps to build stronger
intuition for where the rules of
calculus actually come from but it's not
just some trick for building intuitions
everything I've been saying about
derivatives with this concrete finitely
small nudge philosophy is just a
translation of this formal definition
we're staring at right now so
long story short the big fuss about
limits is that they let us avoid talking
about infinitely small changes by
instead asking what happens as the size
of some small change to our variable
approaches zero and this brings us to
goal number two understanding exactly
what it means for one value to approach
another for example consider the
function two plus h cubed minus two
cubed all divided by H this happens to
be the expression that pops out when you
unravel the definition of a derivative
of X cubed evaluated at x equals two but
let's just think of it as any old
function with an input H its graph is
this nice continuous looking parabola
which would makes sense because it's a
cubic term divided by a linear term but
actually if you think about what's going
on at H equals zero plugging that in you
would get zero divided by zero which is
not defined so really this graph has a
hole at that point and you have to kind
of exaggerate to draw that hole often
with a little empty circle like this but
keep in mind the function is perfectly
well defined for inputs as close to zero
as you want and wouldn't you agree that
as H approaches zero the corresponding
output the height of this graph
approaches twelve and it doesn't matter
which side you come at it from
that limit of this ratio as H approaches
zero is equal to 12 but imagine that you
are a mathematician inventing calculus
and someone skeptically asks you well
what exactly do you mean by approach
that would be kind of an annoying
question I mean come on we all know what
it means for one value to get closer to
another but let's start thinking about
ways that you might be able to answer
that person completely unambiguously
for a given range of inputs within some
distance of zero excluding the forbidden
point zero itself look at all of the
corresponding outputs all possible
heights of the graph above that range as
the range of input values closes in more
and more tightly around zero that range
of output values closes in more and more
closely around 12 and importantly the
size of that range of output values can
be made as small as you want as a
counter example consider a function that
looks like this which is also not
defined at 0 but it kind of jumps up at
that point when you approach H equals 0
from the right the function approaches
the value 2 but as you come at it from
the left it approaches 1 since there's
not a single clear unambiguous value
that this function approaches as H
approaches 0 the limit is simply not
defined at that point one way to think
of this is that when you look at any
range of inputs around zero and consider
the corresponding range of outputs as
you shrink that input range the
corresponding outputs don't narrow in on
any specific value instead those outputs
straddle a range that never shrink
smaller than one even as you make that
input range as tiny as you could imagine
and this perspective of shrinking an
input range around the limiting point
and seeing whether or not you're
restricted in how much that shrinks the
output range leads to something called
the epsilon-delta definition of limits
now I should tell you you could argue
that this is needlessly heavy-duty for
an introduction to calculus like I said
if you know what the word approach means
you already know what a limit means
there's nothing new on the conceptual
level here but this is an interesting
glimpse into the field of real analysis
and it gives you a taste for how
mathematicians make the intuitive ideas
of calculus a little more airtight and
rigorous you've already seen the main
idea here when a limit exists you can
make this output range as small as you
want but when the limit doesn't exist
that output range cannot get smaller
than some particular value no matter how
much you shrink the input range around
the limiting input let's freeze that
same idea but a little more precisely
maybe in the context of this example
where the limiting value was 12 think
about any distance away from 12 where
for some reason is common to use the
Greek letter epsilon to denote that
distance and the intent here is going to
be that this distance epsilon is as
small as you want what it means for the
limit to exist is that you will always
be able to find a range of inputs around
our limiting point some distance Delta
around zero so that any input within
Delta of zero corresponds to an output
within a distance epsilon of 12 and the
key point here is that that's true for
any epsilon no matter how small you'll
always be able to find the corresponding
Delta in contrast when a limit does not
exist as in this example here you can
find a sufficiently small epsilon like
zero point four so that no matter how
small you make your range around zero no
matter how tiny Delta is the
corresponding range of outputs is just
always too big there is no limiting
output where everything is within a
distance epsilon of that output
so far this is all pretty theory heavy
don't you think
limits being used to formally define the
derivative and then epsilon and Delta is
being used to rigorously define the
limit itself so let's finish things off
here with a trick for actually computing
limits for instance let's say for some
reason you were studying the function
sine of pi times x divided by x squared
minus 1 maybe this was modeling some
kind of dampened oscillation when you
plot a bunch of points to graph this it
looks pretty continuous
but there's a problematic value at x
equals 1 when you plug that in sine of
pi is well 0 and the denominator also
comes out to 0 so the function is
actually not defined at that input and
the graph should really have a hole
there this also happens by the way at x
equals negative 1 but let's just focus
our attention on a single one of these
holes for now the graph certainly does
seem to approach a distinct value at
that point wouldn't you say
so you might ask how exactly do you find
what output this approaches as X
approaches 1 since you can't just plug
in 1 well one way to approximate it
would be to plug in a number that's just
really really close to 1 like one point
zero zero zero zero one doing that you'd
find that this should be a number around
negative one point five seven but is
there a way to know precisely what it is
some systematic process to take an
expression like this one that looks like
0/0 at some input and ask what is its
limit as X approaches that input
after limits so helpfully let us write
the definition for derivatives
derivatives can actually come back here
and return the favor
to help us evaluate limits let me show
you what I mean here's what the graph of
sine of pi times X looks like and here's
what the graph of x squared minus 1
looks like that's kind of a lot to have
up on the screen but just focus on
what's happening around x equals 1 the
point here is that sine of pi times X
and x squared minus 1 are both 0 at that
point they both cross the x axis in the
same spirit as plugging in a specific
value near 1 like 1 point 0 0 0 0 1
let's zoom in on that point and consider
what happens just a tiny nudge DX away
from it the value sine of PI times X is
bumped down and the value of that nudge
which was caused by the nudge DX 2 the
input is what we might call D sine of PI
X and from our knowledge of derivatives
using the chain rule that should be
around cosine of pi times x times pi
times DX since the starting value was x
equals 1 we plug in x equals 1/2 that
expression
in other words the amount that this sign
of pi times X graph changes is roughly
proportional to D X with a
proportionality constant equal to cosine
of pi times pi and cosine of pi if we
think back to our trig knowledge is
exactly negative one so we can write
this whole thing as negative pi times DX
similarly the value of the x squared
minus one graph changes by some d x
squared minus one and taking the
derivative the size of that nudge should
be 2x times DX
again we were starting at x equals 1 so
we plug in x equals 1 to that expression
meaning the size of that output nudge is
about 2 times 1 times DX what this means
is that for values of X which are just a
tiny nudge DX away from 1 the ratio sine
of PI X divided by x squared minus 1 is
approximately negative pi times DX
divided by 2 times DX the DX is here
cancel out so what's left is negative PI
over 2 and importantly those
approximations get more and more
accurate for smaller and smaller choices
of DX right so this ratio negative PI
over 2 actually tells us the precise
limiting value as X approaches 1 and
remember what that means is that the
limiting height on our original graph is
evidently exactly negative PI over 2 now
what happened there is a little settle
so I want to go through it again but
this time a little more generally
instead of these two specific functions
which are both equal to 0 at x equals 1
think of any two functions f of X and G
of X which are both 0 at some common
value x equals a the only constraint is
that these have to be functions where
you're able to take a derivative of them
at x equals a which means that they each
basically look like a line when you zoom
in close enough to that value now even
though you can't compute F divided by G
at this trouble point since both of them
equals 0 you can ask about this ratio
for values of X really really close to a
the limit as X approaches a and it's
helpful to think of those nearby inputs
as
a tiny nudge DX away from a the value of
F at that nudged point is approximately
its derivative DF over DX evaluated at a
times DX likewise the value of G at that
nudged point is approximately the
derivative of G evaluated at a times DX
so near that trouble point the ratio
between the outputs of F and G is
actually about the same as the
derivative of F at a times DX divided by
the derivative of G at a times DX those
D X's cancel out so the ratio of F and G
near a is about the same as the ratio
between their derivatives because each
of those approximations gets more and
more accurate for smaller and smaller
nudges this ratio of derivatives gives
the precise value for the limit this is
a really handy trick for computing a lot
of limits whenever you come across some
expression that seems to equal 0/0 when
you plug in some particular input just
try taking the derivative of the top and
bottom expressions and plugging in that
same trouble input this clever trick is
called l'hopital's rule interestingly it
was actually discovered by Johann
Bernoulli but l'hopital was this wealthy
dude who essentially paid Bernoulli for
the rights to some of his mathematical
discoveries academia is weird back then
but hey in a very literal way
it pays to understand these tiny niches
now right now you might be remembering
that the definition of a derivative for
a given function comes down to computing
the limit of a certain fraction that
looks like 0/0 so you might think that
l'hopital's rule could give us a handy
way to discover new derivative formulas
but that would actually be cheating
since presumably you don't know what the
derivative of the numerator here is when
it comes to discovering derivative
formulas something that we've been doing
a fair amount this series there is no
systematic plug and chug method but
that's a good thing
whenever creativity is needed to solve
problems like these it's a good sign
that you're doing something real
something that might give you a powerful
tool to solve future problems
and speaking of powerful tools up next
I'm going to be talking about what an
integral is as well as the fundamental
theorem of calculus and this is another
example of where limits can be used to
help give a clear meaning to a pretty
delicate idea that flirts with infinity
as you know most support for this
channel comes to patreon and the primary
perk for patrons is early access to
future series like this one where the
next one is going to be on probability
but for those of you who want a more
tangible way to flag that you're part of
the community there is also a small
three blue one brown store links on the
screen and in the description I'm still
debating whether or not to make a
preliminary batch of plushie pie
creatures it kind of depends on how many
viewers seem interested in the store
more generally but let me know in
comments what other kinds of things
you'd like to see in there
[Music]
[Music]
you